so with the 20th anniversary of 9 11
just days away biden throws away
everything that's been spent these last
two decades trillions of dollars wasted
thousands of american lives lost even
more lives wrecked as the mothers and
fathers and wives and husbands and sons
and daughters and brothers and sisters
and friends and neighbors of all our
fallen heroes look on in disbelief and
rage
as this bumbling idiot in the white
house this barely lucid puppet of the
establishment this weak incompetent
useless apology for a president erases
practically overnight whatever meager
justification there ever was for this
disastrous misadventure
with the head of the joint chiefs
general mark milley this morning telling
senators on a phone call that thanks to
what is happening in afghanistan right
now thanks to what biden has done these
last few weeks we're going to be more at
risk here in america
how the establishment laughed at trump
for his foreign policy inexperience how
they sneered at him oh he's so ignorant
he doesn't know history he hasn't read
the right books well maybe not but he
knew what he wanted peace through
strength and look what he delivered
china confronted isis defeated iran
depleted america protected
and what have we got now now the
establishment got their wish and put the
great highly experienced foreign policy
genius joe biden into office chaos
calamity weakness wherever you look
chaos at the border as criminals and
smugglers are emboldened chaos in the
middle east as iran is emboldened chaos
in the far east as china is emboldened
and of course
unfolding right before our eyes the
worst chaos the biggest calamity the
most embarrassing weakness of all the
abject humiliation of biden's afghan
debacle
where is biden anyway as the reputation
of his regime and america's standing in
the world collapses around him instead
of leading instead of helping instead of
directing some kind of effort anything
to get americans and our allies out to
advance our interests to salvage
something from the wreckage of his
policies biden's busy playing politics
sitting in his bunker blaming everyone
but himself for this fiasco it's trump's
fault he says he negotiated a bad deal
my hands were tied oh biden's hands were
tied were they funny how they weren't
tied when he totally reversed trump's
iran policy or his border policy or his
energy policy or just about every other
trump policy biden set about reversing
the minute he was inaugurated but no
just this one afghanistan absolutely
impossible to reverse nothing i could do
sorry
what a joke
now they're out trying to blame the
intelligence agencies throwing them
under the bus listen to biden lapdog
congresswoman jackie speer this morning
this is a
crisis of untold proportions this is an
intelligence failure
we underestimated the taliban and
overestimated the resolve of the afghan
army
this is a crucial point and one we all
need to dig into
they're trying to pretend that the
intelligence agencies gave them the all
clear to go ahead with a rushed retreat
community has assessed that the afghan
government will likely collapse that's
not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion
but hang on a second that's not what
others who were briefed on the
intelligence say here's congressman
michael mccall ranking member of the
house foreign affairs committee today
did the strength of the taliban and you
know jake they didn't listen to the
intelligence community because every
time i got an ic briefing assessment it
was probably the grimmest assessment
i've ever heard on afghanistan
so let's just be very clear what's going
on here this is shaping up to be a
scandal of iraq wmd proportions biden
the democrats are blaming the
intelligence for this disaster they
never told us this could happen they
said it would be fine if we pulled out
overnight there's no way the taliban
could take over but based on what
michael mccall is saying about the
intelligence biden is lying
so is congresswoman jackie spears so are
all the democrats who are trying to
shift blame onto the intelligence
agencies let's play the crucial tape one
more time
intelligence community has assessed that
the afghan government will likely
collapse that's not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion
right that was july the 8th this is what
every so-called journalist in washington
should be focused on finding out what
exactly was biden told by the
intelligence agencies and did he lie
about it in that july 8 press conference
biden's blaming the intelligence he's
blaming trump next would be blaming the
delta variant for his afghan disaster or
people who don't wear masks or racism
anything and anyone except the person
who's actually responsible himself yes
trump wanted to end the afghan war and
bring our troops home but he gave the
taliban conditions and threatened
consequences if they broke them as
iran's terror chief qasim sulaimani
found out those were no idle threats
instead from biden we got nothing but
weakness and ineptitude in pursuit of a
transparently political deadline of
getting out by september the 11th the
very fact that he just had to send
another 5 000 troops back in shows how
little proper planning went into getting
them out
but biden's desperate attempts to shift
blame aren't fooling anyone even his own
side here's ryan crocker who was
hand-picked by obama to be america's
ambassador in kabul when let's remember
biden was vice president
it is
beyond disingenuous for the president to
say now we've made all these inputs and
that's up to them to fight for their own
country when he embraced the process uh
and he owns it lock stock and barrel uh
president trump's process
uh guaranteeing
that the government would probably not
survive
he said in another interview quote i'm
left with some grave questions in my
mind about his biden's ability to lead
our nation as commander-in-chief to have
read this so wrong or even worse to have
understood what was likely to happen and
not care
biden's attempts to avoid accountability
and responsibility are truly shameful
but there's something even worse
the disgusting spectacle of the authors
of two decades of american woe two
decades of death and destruction somehow
trying to extract some sick vindication
from all this see we were right all
along we need more troops over there the
war must go on forever insist the neocon
lunatics
the media try and blame trump but no one
points out that if there's one president
and one administration that really
deserves to be held accountable for the
catastrophe of afghanistan it's george w
bush who squandered the world's good
will over 9 911 diverting the focus from
legitimate intervention in pursuit of al
qaeda and instead lying to take us to
war in iraq but of course the media
won't say anything against bush because
he hates trump so they love him
and the brazen neocons keep going like a
bunch of bloodthirsty zombies we saw it
just this morning the dark queen of them
all liz cheney this woman who sacrificed
her own sister for her political career
now touring the tv studios to exploit
america's humiliation in pursuit of her
own deranged personal vendetta how dare
they how dare they after all they've
done to this country in the world still
after all these years all this evidence
of their twisted ideologies utter
failure they want more more troops more
equipment more foreign adventures always
more war we know why because war is the
cheney family business fought by other
people's children for their personal
gain
war is the corrupt military industrial
complexes business the clueless defense
and security establishments business all
of them getting rich as the world burns
finally with president trump we had a
leader who stood outside that disastrous
corrupt groupthink
and showed there is a different way
you don't have to invade other countries
to defend this one
you don't have to send young americans
to their deaths to save lives here
peace through strength
for four years it worked
but now we're back to the worst of it
all
under biden the feeble puppet of a
failed establishment it's not peace
through strength it is the exact
opposite
chaos through
weakness hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else